well the first minister of wales mark
drakeford joins us now timing is
everything as the prisons minister was
telling us there mr drakeford
and we're expecting an announcement from
you today about uh the lifting of
lockdown restrictions in wales
or not as the case may be just tell us
what is the current situation there
well there's grounds for optimism in
wales at the moment
the number of people suffering from
coronavirus
is declining every day not low enough
there's further ground to gain
the numbers in our hospitals are
stubbornly high but just beginning to
decline
i'm going to have to explain today that
the current lockdown measures
will need to continue for a further
three weeks in order to build on the
progress we've made so far
but with some plans beyond that to begin
the lifting of the lockdown
and so you're my understanding looking
at possibly looking re-opening schools
from the 22nd of february the week after
half term
well schools are our top priority if
there is any head room after the next
three weeks
we will use it to begin a phased and
flexible return of our young people
to face-to-face learning children and
young people have had an absolutely
torrid time over the last 12 months
and our cabinet is determined that they
will have priority
when it comes to be able to begin the
lifting of the lockdown
we'll work hard with our local education
authorities and trade unions over the
next week
to plan for that it won't be every child
by any means back in the classroom
but we can begin that process after the
22nd of february
provided the numbers continue to move in
the right direction
what about vaccine teachers would that
be a good idea vaccinating them
well we follow the advice of the joint
committee on vaccination and
immunization
they look all the time at the priority
groups if they tell us that we should
move teachers or other professional
groups
up the priority order that is what we
will do
at the moment their advice is that we
should stick with the nine priority
groups
they've identified at the outset we will
follow the best advice available in the
united kingdom
and that advice would change then we
would change with it
why why is it that wales has missed it
its vaccine targets when they seem to
have
gone relatively smoothly around england
you were supposed to have
got to 70 of the over 80s by the weekend
but but you haven't why
uh well we just missed it at the weekend
because we had the weekend of
snow flooding and ice in many parts of
wales i'm confident we will have reached
that during the week as we caught up on
the appointments that people over 18
were simply unable to
uh attend because they couldn't leave
their homes because of weather
conditions
who sorry saw we were slightly
interested in time but there are critics
who say that
you slow down the role of the pfizer uh
vaccine
why why did you do that initially
wouldn't that have had an impact well we
didn't do it
that is simply not true we are using
every drop of vaccine that we have
whether that's pfizer or the oxford
vaccine
we will have vaccinated a higher
proportion of our population in the last
seven days
than any other part of the united
kingdom
but the race is not with other countries
the race is with the virus
a race between infection and injection
and we are on track in wales to deliver
what we promised
the top four priority groups will all
have been offered
vaccination by the middle of february we
have 400
gp practices now involved in the
vaccination effort here in wales
it's a huge success story and one which
people should be proud of
do you have an issue with vaccine
supplies you know nicolas sturgeon
uh has talked about possibly releasing
information about the vaccine supplies
being offered to scotland is that an
issue and something you would maybe do
as well
uh well the thing that limits our
ability to vaccine vaccinate more people
at the moment is supply but that's true
everywhere
in the united kingdom if we had more of
the vaccine we would be able to
vaccinate
more people it's why today's
announcement of a fourth vaccine going
to
the regulator for approval is good news
uh so you don't you don't think actually
publishing any any kind of figures
is particularly useful well we were
about to publish figures here in wales
we publish more data
uh than would be the case across our
border in england we were asked not to
by the uk government there's a lot of
sensitivity at the moment as you know
across the whole of europe about
supplies of vaccine
uh while uh the uk government tells us
that it would not be sensible
we will take that advice seriously we're
not going to publish it at the moment
when the as soon as it's safe to do so
and right to do so we will put that
information
into the public domain okay mark draper
good to talk to you thank you very much